bonsoir thomas on le voit thomas les
états unis n'ont de ces derniers jours
le monde d'informations alarmistes sur
une attaque imminente et dernière
information en date il y à quelques
minutes les états unis qui déclare
transférer même leur ambassade de kiev
oui c'est la dernière illustration en
date de cet alarmisme côté américain le
chef de la diplomatie américaine anthony
blinken annonce donc à l'instant le
déplacement de l'ambassade américaine de
kiev vers l'ouest de l'ukraine on
rappelle que washington exhorte les
ressortissants américains à quitter
l'ukraine au plus vite alors un peu plus
tôt ce lundi c'est le porte parole du
pentagone john kirby qui sur cnn
affirmaient que la russie a renforcé ses
capacités militaires le long de la
frontière ukrainienne durant le week-end
des déclarations qui s'inscrivent dans
la lignée des messages de plus en plus
alarmistes de la part des autorités
américaines
le point d'orgue de cet alarmisme
c'était une conférence de presse
vendredi dernier à la maison blanche en
présence du conseiller à la sécurité
nationale hajek sullivan il a tenu le
discours le plus alarmiste depuis le
début de la crise ukrainienne en tout
cas du côté américain écouter
quelques-unes de ses interventions
il est difficile d'attribuer un
pourcentage de probabilité à tout cela
nous devons penser à l'éventail de
scénarios auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et c'est notre travail d'être
prêt pour chacun d'entre eux ce que je
dirais c'est que la façon dont la russie
à constituer ses forces et les a mises
en place ainsi que les autres
indicateurs que nous avons recueillis
par le biais du renseignement nous
montre clairement qu'il ya une très
forte possibilité que la russie
choisissent d'agir militairement et
qu'il y a des raisons de croire que cela
pourrait se produire dans un délai
raisonnablement rapide
jack sullivan qui persiste puisque ce
week-end il affirmait qu'une action
militaire pourrait être lancé a très
rapidement il évoque même la possibilité
que cela se produise je cite dès cette
semaine et dans le même temps des médias
américains citent des sources des
services de renseignement pour affirmer
qu'une offensive russe contre l'ukraine
pourrait avoir lieu le mercredi
février c'est après-demain des
allégations étonnamment précise et qui
laisse également sceptique un certain
nombre de diplomates européens mais tout
cela est relayée abondamment dans les
médias américains depuis des semaines on
assiste à un durcissement de ton contre
la russie de la part de la presse
américaine avec des affirmations
répétées selon lesquelles la guerre est
imminente est quasiment inéluctable avec
donc des services de renseignement qui
abreuvent les journalistes d'éléments
des éléments qui sont souvent repris
pour argent comptant alors il ya quand
même à des informations les affirmations
officielles qui sont parfois contesté
publiquement se souvient de cette scène
entre le journaliste de help him as tu
lis et le porte-parole de la diplomatie
américaine nike price le journaliste lui
demandait d'étayer les accusations
américaines selon lesquelles la russie
pourrait fomenté une attaque sous faux
drapeau pour avoir un prétexte pour
oeuvre envahir l'ukraine il faut aussi
préciser qu'il y à quelques voix qui
s'élèvent contre le discours alarmiste
des autorités américaines dernièrement
ses atouts le sig à barbe l'ancien
parlementaire démocrate qui évoquait
notamment les enjeux nationaux qui
peuvent aussi expliquer le
positionnement de la maison blanche sur
le dossier ukrainien il ya aussi un
certain nombre de personnes qui
rappellent le précédent des services de
renseignements et leur implication dans
la guerre en irak en 2003 en tout cas
pour finir on voit que ce discours
alarmiste semble moins imprimés auprès
des plus jeunes américains selon un
sondage une majorité des américains de
18 à 29 ans souhaiterait que les
etats-unis se tiennent éloignés des
discussions entre la russie et l'ukraine
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington